The word for how in Spanish is como.
Como.
How do you think you would say how are you?
talking informally.
Como estás?
¿Cómo estás?
Because when you ask somebody how they are, you're referring to their state.
And formally how would you ask?
Como está?
Good.
And if you were asking more than one person?
Very nice.
The word for where is donde.
So how would you say
Where are you talking informally?
Don't de estas Donde estas I don't know where we are.
So what was I don't know
No sé.
Good.
I don't know where we are.
So no sé donde estamos.
Good.
No sé dónde estamos.
How do you say I am here?
Estoy aquí, estoy acá.
How would you say I want to be here?
Quiero estar aquí.
Good.
How would you say I'm going to be here later?
What was the word for late?
We say we use tarde.
Good.
And later or more late?
Mastarde.
Good.
So I'm going to be here later.
Boy a estar aquí más tarde.
Boy is I go or I'm going.
How do you say you go or you are going speaking informally?
Bas.
Good.
So how do you say where are you going to be?
So break it up.
Where are you going to be?
Donde vas a estar.
Yes, donde vas a estar.
Where are you going to be?
Good.
So let's run through the forms again and let's use the words for emphasis just to practice them.
So I am is Yo estoy.
Good.
Yo estoy.
He is
El esta.
Good.
She is.
Ella está.
Good.
And you talking for me are
Usted está.
Good.
They are, using the word for they.
Ellos están.
Ellas están.
Good.
What is we are?
Nosotros estamos.
Good.
And for feminine?
So nosotros changes to nosotras.
You are talking informally.
Estás.
Good.
And if we use the word for you, tu estás.
Tu estás.
Good.
How would you ask
More than one person, where do you have to be later?
So the first bit is where
Do you have?
And we are talking to you plural, which is the same as they.
Do you have
Yeah, what's to have?
Um tener.
Tener, good.
And we have it as tain in words like maintain, mantener, contain, contener.
Sustain, sustener, entertain, and retener, obtain, obtener.
That will help us.
So first we want to build you guys have from tener
Good.
So where do you have to be later?
To you plural triad
Donde tienen Estan Slower.
Oh sorry, to be.
It's in the yes.
Donde and I've forgotten the other one now.
It's okay, work it out again.
Donde tienen estar.
There is something we need to add to tienen to get this meaning of have to.
And it's not a comfortable translation.
Donde tienen que estar later.
Más tarde.
¿Dónde tienen que estar más tarde?
Good.
You might want to say he must be here.
And you can use this in the same way as you do in in English to refer to probability.
Oh he must be here by now or something like this.
You have the same use in Spanish.
And must is the same as
to owe which is related to debt.
So what was to O?
Deber.
Good.
So he owes or he must
Debe.
This E doesn't split.
Good.
Debe.
So he must be here.
Debe estar aquí.
Good.
And he must be tired.
Debe estar cansado.
Good.
They must be tired.
Very good.
What if they were females?
Cas cansadas.
All together.
Don't miss the fun, I mean.
Deben estar cansadas.
Good.
To remain was quedar.
And to get the meaning of I stay, we say I remain myself.
So how would that sound?
I remain myself
Mekedo.
I'm staying.
How would we are staying or we remain ourselves be?
Nos quedamos.
Good.
We are not going to stay because we are very tired
We are not going to stay because we are very tired.
So the first bit that needs to command all of our attention is we are not going.
No vamos.
We are not going to stay.
So we are not going to remain ourselves.
No vamos a quedarnos.
Good.
No vamos a quedarnos or no nos vamos a quedar.
You could have this as well.
No nos vamos a quedar.
Because?
Same as why?
Porque.
Porque we are very tired.
And let's be a masculine or a mixed group.
We are very tired.
Good.
Now all together and not from memory.
Thinking about it again, block by block, if you rush it, you will trip, and tripping is very time consuming.
So we are not going to remain ourselves, to stay.
No vamos a quedarnos.
Good, because we are very tired.
Good.
Well done.
No vamos a quedarnos.
No nos vamos a quedar.
Very good.